[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
happy happy happy friday
thanks for joining us here on the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
every single weekday two hours
we got the bonehead of the week today
you guys voted in the poll
on tony michael's pod the twitter
account
and we have the results for you today so
we will go through all the results of
the bonehead of the week
paul everyone's here hi kaelin you're
here barely you're still uh
having coveted symptoms it sounds like
me too what's up kaelin how are you
feeling mj says everyone's feeling for
caitlin this morning
uh yoda says morning k
morning tony morning good morning
morning
uh lisa is concerned about caitlin too
uh good morning lisa good morning robin
how are you everyone's here today what's
up what's up mj
we are all here
to go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends you guys seen that uh
there's a there's a bridge that fell
four years we had infrastructure week
four [ __ ] years we had infrastructure
week while the cheeto mussolini was
[ __ ] golfing the gqp did nothing
absolutely [ __ ] nothing
democrats finally deliver
not in time for one in particular bridge
in pittsburgh
but here we are
we have a we have the president united
states going to pittsburgh today after a
bridge falls into a ravine
luckily killing no one no fatalities
no major injuries either
which is really surprising if you see
the pictures
but then you have ron desantis down in
south florida taking it taking credit
for 80 million dollars of checks that
he's passing out today of a bill he
called socialism
i said this today watch watch how
infrastructure isn't socialism today new
bridge socialism socialism new bridge
socialism
a broken bridge in pittsburgh brandon
brandon did it brandon did it brandon
did it that's what they're gonna do
100 full stop
no doubt about it
so let's get some announcements out of
the way you guys know on monday we're
going to have a interview with missy
modell
you guys need to go follow missy on tick
tock if you're not on tick tock download
that app i mean it's a kids dancing app
but you ain't got to go in it just to
look at some particular things you know
gabe's got all his videos over there
and i'll tell on him you just go down
his tick tock feed there are dancing
videos of gabe on tiktok they're there
i promise you you just go to the very
bottom there's a lot of videos he's got
a lot of videos you just go to the
bottom
i hope he's listening right now and he
knows
i i will tell you on my tick tock
account there are dancing videos too
it's [ __ ] embarrassing but i keep
them there for your enjoyment that's
that's what we do over on tic tac when
you first get the app you don't know
what to do so you're doing these stupid
dancing trends you just do that kind of
[ __ ] over there
it's ridiculous but you do it
i don't know what to tell you go
download the app i don't get paid for
telling you to download the app but go
watch missy's
parody
uh parody songs they're [ __ ]
fantastic
and we asked her about those parody
songs in the interview and like how she
makes them how she comes up with them
like how they click and how they get
made and she so she tells you a little
bit about that in the interview we play
trivia of course her and gabe
um play trivia
and then we ask her about trolls and
troll farms and people trolling you and
taking breaks mental health breaks from
social media i think that's important to
talk about uh so she talks about we talk
about that in that in that interview
that we're um gonna air on monday we
have a few more interviews
that are set to be recorded this is
gonna be fun i like having two hours a
day where we can just air an interview
whenever we want right like so when we
get an interview we get someone we get
it recorded
we'll just air it we'll announce it a
day or two before we'll air it and then
you guys can enjoy the interview and
then we'll do the next one and the next
one so some weeks we might have two
interviews some weeks might have one so
might some weeks might have one almost
every single day
it's it's fantastic
we're very excited about being on two
hours a day every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central youtube twitter
twitch so don't forget to go you
subscribe to the youtube channel
and hit the thumbs up button and hit the
bell no
you know you know me i i don't know i
don't know that all the youtube lingo
do that whatever it is that it's
supposed to that i'm supposed to say
pretend i said it and then do that thing
just make sure you don't miss the show
now if you do miss the show it is not
that big of a deal it really isn't
because it's on youtube it's up there
and if you guys noticed i've been
cutting out some certain clips
that i feel like are relevant to the
news
maybe like one of the top stories or
something
um so i've been cutting some clips there
and if you go on twitch some of you get
the twitch app you can actually cut out
30 seconds clips of the show yourself on
there i think i don't know how it works
but you can do that i don't know
and then to all of you out there on
twitter keep keep watching on twitter as
well
because we want you to watch on twitter
two hours
every single weekday
right here youtube twitter twitch
so uh i think we should uh take a break
here and then we come back we'll get
into the [ __ ] list roundup so we'll be
right back after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you know we have bonehead of the week
today
second hour of the show
bonehead of the week
[Music]
we got a dishonorable mention this week
that you guys will
you guys will know him
[Laughter]
but go over and uh follow at tony
michael's pod i also follow me and gabe
on twitter um and and go over there the
results are closed at this point for
this week but you can go see the results
of this week's bonehead of the week poll
um they're all they're all over there
everything everything's over there
everything's over there so go check that
out so we'll do bonehead in the second
hour of today uh we're 10 minutes into
the first hour already you know how many
i just chat and chat and chat and chat
and chat
so we will um
we'll get to the bonehead of the week
gable join us for that
there's a lot of stuff in the news today
on the [ __ ] list
uh you know the white house has a new
cat
and pittsburgh is looking for a new
bridge let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome to the shitless roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends of the day you
know that's what we do here on the [ __ ]
list roundup on the tony michaels
podcast
every single weekday noon eastern 11
center for two full hours
every single weekday monday through
friday
monday through friday
okay let's let's let's just get into
this here um on the timeline because
there's a lot of stuff to go through
today the news seemed kind of thin this
morning uh but it really started to pick
up pretty god damn fast
uh you know uh here here's uh here's one
tweet i wanna show you guys let's let's
make this bigger here
you don't want to see my face you want
to see the tweets you want to see the
tweets and the trendy trends right okay
so rachel you know you guys know i had
rachel on earlier this week uh we talked
about strategic outrage i hope to have
her every week or every couple weeks to
talk about strategic outrage how we're
going to win the 2022 midterms you guys
know rachel bitkoffer is the is the
political strategist with strike pack
that came up with the 2018 plan to take
back the house which was successful uh
hopefully hopefully we can all get on
board
and uh institute her 2022 plan that she
has
she says gop says they want to make
education a prime focus in 2022. well
here's how you beat him to death on it
oh really well you want to increase guns
in schools you want to ban books
right you want to spread covet and you
want to gut funding
always always want to gut funding that's
the first [ __ ] funding these state
legislators go after is education in
these states when they're republicans
and gut funding they don't like public
education they don't want people to be
educated that's the [ __ ] simple fact
if people are educated how the [ __ ]
would they be republicans huh at this
point jesus [ __ ] christ
how would you expect anyone who's
educated to even remotely look like a
[ __ ] republican and i'm not talking
about like college educated i'm talking
about like common [ __ ] sense
common [ __ ] sense so go watch the the
i cut out the the conversation we had
earlier this week with rachel on the
youtube channel so go go watch that
thank you rachel for your tweet
as always you guys need to go follow
rachel um she's posting every single day
how to message
like if you want to know how to message
go follow rachel and follow her lead
that's how we're gonna do this thing uh
because she has no [ __ ] left to give
not not [ __ ] one of them and if you
don't believe me go watch the damn
conversation we had uh earlier this week
i cut it out of the pot out of the
podcast or you can watch the whole
podcast with her in it as well
but she she was on um and it's it's on
the youtube channel just go to my
youtube channel and search rachel
bitcoffer and then the interview from
several weeks goes on there too but we
hope to have rachel on as a regular
guest to give us the lowdown of what the
2022 race looks like as we continue on
into 2022 and into the cycle of the
midterm the primaries and then the
general election
all right thank you rachel oh look
mayo one of our favorite is mayo out
there good morning to everyone and i
hope you have a wonderful friday we hope
you have a wonderful friday too mayo
everyone say happy friday to mayo
one of our favorites one of our
favorites thank you mayo uh here's the
bridge
uh in in pittsburgh
that fell
uh into the ravine
uh
there's also some other pictures and
we'll get into this a little more once
we get into the thread um there's some
pictures of underneath this bridge that
people have been posting for years where
this [ __ ] bridge was being held
together by cables
by [ __ ] cables
that's right
cables were holding this bridge together
not actual structure the structure was
rotten and rusted all the way through so
they you know this just you know
just wire it together why not you know
get some twisty ties and tie that
[ __ ] together
this is the reason why we need
infrastructure this is a reason why we
have to have government spending in
these areas who the [ __ ] else is gonna
fix this bridge who
who's gonna fix it
elon musk is he gonna go pay for that
[ __ ] [ __ ] no he won't even pay
taxes now
[ __ ]
what do we what
who's gonna pay for who
how are you gonna do it
they yelled and screamed ron desantis
that [ __ ] yelled and screamed about how
infrastructure was socialism this is
this is the result of a bitching about
socialism people right here this is the
result of letting them [ __ ] pin us up
in some kind of [ __ ] commie radicals
like oh we want to have safe bridges you
know radical [ __ ] like that get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
if anyone sees this picture and isn't
completely [ __ ] pissed off at the
republican party i don't you're not
doing it right
you're not doing it right
there's not one goddamn democrat that
doesn't want bridges to have funding not
one and they're not going to go around
and call it oh socialism socialism
socialism socialism it's a [ __ ]
bridge
school bus is full of children drive
across this [ __ ] bridge
got it yeah we know you don't give a
[ __ ] about children you [ __ ]
like eric schmidt here in missouri who's
running around telling school boards
what they can and can't do with masks to
protect children from a [ __ ] deadly
virus
go vote go vote republican in 2022 and
see how many [ __ ] more bridges fall
into ravines
my comment was watch how infrastructure
isn't socialism today
it's true today it won't be socialism
tomorrow it'll it'll be brandon's fault
today
tomorrow it'll be socialism again these
[ __ ]
you see how they're tearing our country
down do you see how do you see how the
cheeto mussolini jesus
destroyed our country while he was
golfing
while he was paying attention to ukraine
and trying to make sure that he had a
quid pro crow with ukraine
so that way he could beat joe biden
because he knew he knew joe biden was
gonna spank his [ __ ] ass
he knew it he knew it that's why he knew
he had to have the quid pro quo in his
back pocket you know that perfect phone
call and all that [ __ ] no collusion
no obstruction
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
they want to release the tape today of
joe biden talking to the ukrainian
prison
[Laughter]
see you know what's funny about that
what's funny about they want they want
joe biden to release the tape where he
talks to ukrainian prison is normally
presidents don't have to release tapes
where they talk to foreign leaders
because they don't commit crimes on them
you dumb [ __ ]
that's why that's why presidents don't
have to release the [ __ ] tapes when
they talk to foreign leaders generally
speaking
because generally speaking democrat and
republicans don't commit crimes on calls
with foreign leaders
that not only you can be impeached for
and removed but should be prosecuted for
for bribery
you [ __ ] that's why the tape of joe
biden is gonna get released you [ __ ]
num num skulls
jesus christ you can't it it just it all
it all just piles on top of each other
with these [ __ ] they can't help
themselves um you know bump here here
here you go here's my tweet president
biden pressured the ukraine president to
investigate his political opponent in a
quid pro quo for foreign aid high crime
stuff oh wait checks notes oops i
misspelled here that may be and that may
have been someone else
you [ __ ] morons
let's see what else we got here
i didn't retweet a lot of stuff this
morning i think it's because i wanted to
get into the threads oh wait what is
this
what is this is this a video about
tucker carlson and m m's oh my god
maybe maybe we should see what this
video is i don't know
we find silly videos here on the
internet i'm sure this is legit
uh robin says so frustrating all of it
100
yeah
and it's crazy crazy ass [ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ] anonymous says lazy
bastard i don't know if you're talking
oh mj says hey gabe they're
lazy bastard anonymous says
lisa said who dad i don't know who this
is i don't know who this is but it looks
like someone in a wig didn't it
ah this guy in his [ __ ] wigs this guy
can you imagine being this guy's
neighbor
you know look at this window seeing this
guy
dressing up in all kinds of wigs and
stuff like what is going on in that
place he's yelling and screaming in
there he's changing he's changing
personalities they think they think he's
absolutely bad [ __ ] crazy they have to
they have to let's watch this tucker was
fine at first but then he went all
psycho on me
well for starters he would text me
non-stop while i was on set red flag he
became obsessive demanding to see my
emails where i was going who i was with
double red flag then he would text me
ideas about changing my looks that i
would be sweeter if i were white
chocolate they aren't even chocolate
just sugar and bland vanilla hey
all chocolates matter ugly chef and
remember when i started wearing sneakers
because i kept losing my go-go boots
yeah well it turns out tucker was
stealing them filling them with
chocolate and then [ __ ] them and
that's not even the weird part he was
speaking russian while doing it in front
of a bed full of minnie mouse styles and
mr potato heads ugh he's just like matt
gates and then he showed up to my house
at three in the morning with the boombox
reenacting the scene from say anything
so what did you do i filed a restraining
order and then he told me you'll regret
the day you were coded what does that
even mean he'll probably say something
dumb on his entertainment show
unappealing and totally androgynous
until the moment you wouldn't want to
have a drink with any one of them that's
the goal when you're totally turned off
we've achieved equity
oh thank you to the green m m
and kitkat
hell mayo's here hey mayo good morning
uh caitlyn brings up the uh story about
sarah palin
uh dining after testing positive for
cova did you guys see this story hey
let's see if we can go find this story
that's a good story before we get into
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
here let's see if we can let's see if we
can find this story
to see if it comes up under say or sarah
palin uh here it is two days after sarah
palin test deposit for coronavirus the
former alaskan governor dined outdoors
in new york city on wednesday evening
defying federal guidance guidance that
infected so she was dining outdoors um
here's here's uh here we go
here's the
video from ron
let's see if we can
looks like just a few seconds here but
let's let's see
we're gonna go to your place
when they say when they say she's dining
outdoors
i i have a hard time believing that this
is i mean this may be outdoors that you
tested positive for covid
i'm just curious i'm just curious yeah
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] that's good i like it i like it
yeah go right after this so you goddamn
right i'm looking for trouble and her
name is covid
what the [ __ ] you know of course they
did they probably wouldn't let her
inside the restaurant because she
doesn't have a vaccine card but why they
would sit her in here in this little
room here is beyond me because there's
other tables in this little room this
this is this is outdoors but this is
loosely outdoors folks don't you think
don't you think in this in this video i
mean look at this
that's that's loosely outdoors
i mean uh maybe there's vents in the in
in this thing i don't know like it's
hard to tell but this is this this is
this is loosely outdoors
okay well
it is what it is uh of course you know
she's a kobe spreader which is not
surprising it's not [ __ ] surprising
that she's a [ __ ] kobe spreader
here's another video of it
now happening now sarah palin seen
dining at the manhattan restaurant she
is in the city for a trial against new
new york times
which is reportedly delayed due to her
testing positive for kobe two days ago
according to forbes
here's uh well you know we can watch
this video a little bit of it here
now again this is supposed to be
outdoors
[Music]
kinda
[Music]
what what is that
what did she do
okay so she's going inside
somewhere i don't know is that a rest is
that an office or something
or is that that can't be the restaurant
no that looks like an apartment or naval
building
did she go in the restaurant
of course she's spreading her covet all
over these people look at this
all these unsuspecting
i'm fast forwarding because i don't want
to watch it hurt dumbass
okay i guess i guess the uh the the
consensus here is maybe maybe she is
vaccinated right i mean are you allowed
i mean i thought you were allowed to
you couldn't eat i mean we've seen all
these people you know get handcuffed and
carried oh we can't get our cheesecake
we can't get our cheesecake because we
won't prove we're vaccinated i mean
maybe the cheesecake factory doesn't
have an outdoor dining spot i don't know
it's really it's really [ __ ]
weird that someone who's tested positive
for covid who knows that it's a deadly
pathogen
is just
running around spreading it to everybody
hmm
[ __ ] bonehead
dangerous as [ __ ] what an absolute idiot
uh well here's wu-tang for children is
this uh that was on the 24th so that's
before i thought maybe that was her
responding
of course she's a she's a [ __ ]
knuckle dragger so it's not surprising
all right let's go to the tweety tweets
and trendy trends you guys know that
pittsburgh is trending for the uh the
bridge uh you seen this earlier the ap
reports breaking and bridge collapse in
pittsburgh hours before president biden
was scheduled to visit the city to talk
about infrastructure bill of course
there's going to be conspiracy theories
about that
police reported that the span came down
around 6 a.m so really early in the
morning authorities said there was no
initial reports of injuries so no
injuries have been reported that's
that's the actual good thing about um
this bridge collapsing this morning
that's the silver lining is no one was
injured um you can see in the picture
though there's a there's a city bus a
couple cars here um on the bridge now
this bridge has [ __ ] school buses
school buses go across it now this was
you can see around 6 a.m
6 a.m so just just probably in the next
couple hours there are going to be
school bus loads of children going
across this bridge
school bus loads of them
i don't know how many school buses cross
this bridge today but it's probably
several
not a long
let alone with the city buses and
everything else
and and hopefully in this thread here
we'll see some of these pictures that i
was talking about earlier where the
supports are completely rusted [ __ ]
through and they got this son of a [ __ ]
held together with [ __ ] with [ __ ]
bailing twine
um yeah it might as well be mine is
[ __ ] well be here's another picture
barbara has it not for nothing but trump
had four years to get infrastructure
done but was too busy playing golf on
our dollar no [ __ ] when president biden
visits pittsburgh today to talk about
the bipartisan infrastructure bill i
don't think it's bipartisan this is not
a bipartisan infrastructure bill if it
was so [ __ ] bipartisan why did they
try so goddamn hard to stop it
it was only when they had to vote when
they had to make their legacy vote that
they took it he wouldn't have to look
far
for the need
so i agree with everything she says but
the bipartisan it isn't bipartisan they
don't give a [ __ ] about infrastructure
these [ __ ] governors fought tooth and
nail to call this and pin this up as
socialism they didn't want joe biden to
have a win
own the libs
at every cost
and then when you get in government you
can't [ __ ] manage to pin
put together a [ __ ] infrastructure
package that everyone can agree on
that would have been a bipartisan bill
if trump would have brought an actual
infrastructure bill to congress
not one of them reached the house floor
not one of them reached the senate floor
because they don't give a [ __ ] about
infrastructure
infrastructure is tax dollars
you gotta tax their [ __ ] donors you
got to tax the american people to pay
for infrastructure that's where it comes
from that's where that where do you
think this money just falls out of
someone's ass
no it's tax dollars
now we should be taxing the rich to pay
for all this [ __ ]
how many amazon trucks you think drive
across this [ __ ] every day how
many [ __ ] amazon trucks do you think
drive across this bridge every goddamn
day how much money does amazon make
every day because this bridge didn't
collapse
huh
put it in that way think about it in
that form for a minute
bipartisan
i'm sorry barbara but i disagree with
you on the bipartisan thing full stop
and ain't bipartisan they don't give a
[ __ ] about this bridge the only reason
why they're gonna give a [ __ ] about it
today is because let's go brandon
that's all they're gonna be giving a
[ __ ] about this nonsense complete
[ __ ] nonsense here's some here's some
more up close pictures of this bridge
um you can see there this car
and then the the bus here and there's
some cars down here at the bottom
and it looks like appears maybe there be
maybe something down here in the ravine
now this looks like a very
very very uh
wow i'm surprised no one was injured
here but
this is a
crazy crazy visuals let's go back to the
other pictures here um here's a closer
picture of this city bus
it's lucky this bridge didn't collapse
on top and crush this bus
jesus christ and here's the cars down at
their in the middle of the bridge it
looks appears to be three of them
um one completely turned over
oh boy
i i'd say they filled their pants when
this bridge was coming down holy [ __ ]
um
aj plus here at snow covered bridge
collapsed in pittsburgh hours before the
visit by biden rescuers um formed a
human chain to rescue people in the
dangling bus
no deaths reported the cause is being
investigated some people threaten are
excuse me treated for minor
injuries
and now
close gas leak
uh so there was a gas leak apparently
there was probably a gas line that was
going across this bridge some kind of
utility maybe
um they do that a lot they use the
bridge to span
utilities across
okay let's let's go back to this thread
i want to see these pictures because
someone was posting pictures earlier
from a couple years ago
and those pictures
showed the underside of this bridge
before it collapsed
where in the [ __ ] is that
picture
it's in this thread somewhere
more than likely
we will find it
uh what the picture that i seen was the
actual support the angle support of the
bridge rusted all the way through from
the upright to the support
and what was taking place in the picture
also was that the bridge was being held
together by cables
with that particular structure
point um not not not repaired and welded
uh this is a very very good uh video
stephanie has here every day melissa
takes her daughter across this
pittsburgh bridge that collapsed this
morning today there was a delay
due to snow behind her a port authority
bus balance his nose down in the
wreckage
these hours ahead of biden's visit to
the city to discuss infrastructure
listen listen to what uh melissa has to
say here
she is a a mom who drives across this
bridge every single day take my daughter
across this bridge like every day
and it could have been any of us sitting
at that light
i mean thank god for the delay because
there's always school buses sitting at
that light there's schools
elementary schools all along this road
it's really scary take my daughter
across this bridge like every day
and it could have been any of us sitting
at that lake it's just a matter of
timing
so so lucky that the bridge wasn't full
when it collapsed that it only had a few
cars and this bus on it and no one was
injured
jesus [ __ ] christ
god damn
this is america folks this is america
good lord
okay let's see here let's give credit
for that i'll retweet that so you guys
can go
watch that video again go retweet that
video that's a hell of a video
of a mom who drives across that bridge
every goddamn day you want to know how
important that bridge is you wanna know
how [ __ ] important that bridge is to
be safe for a mom to get her kid to
school
got it you got it you dumb [ __ ]
wake the [ __ ] up pull pluck your head
out of your [ __ ] ass pluck it out of
your ass and understand what the [ __ ]
going on how these people are
gaslighting you with [ __ ] dr seuss mr
potato head m ms and [ __ ] minnie
mouse you dumb [ __ ]
you people listening to hours and hours
and hours of tucker carlson [ __ ] about
how he he doesn't like m m's anymore
because they don't have sexy asses
he can't [ __ ] him anymore
and you people run around tweeting and
yelling and screaming about eminem's
and there's a brit there's bridges all
over the country not just this one
that parents like you with kids like
yours who take them to school like you
do that ride buses across those bridges
every [ __ ] day
we got the money
we got the money
the only reason why we haven't had an
infrastructure bill is because
republicans destroy
everything [ __ ] everything
they don't give a [ __ ] about your bridge
they don't give a [ __ ] about you taking
your kid to school they don't give a
[ __ ]
never have never will they just want to
make sure that their donors money don't
go to paying for bridges so you can get
your kids to school
facts
[ __ ] ridiculous i i know
there is the picture
somewhere of the other side of this
bridge now it's being buried here
because there is so many pictures of the
collapsed bridge
here it is right here
dr g
kokatsk konoski
i hope someone is keeping an eye on this
underside of the forbes
avenue bridge over frisk park
one of the biggest x beams has rusted
through entirely and yes i see the
cables so it's probably not a crisis
look at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you see the x beam here the cross beam
it is totally totally separated from the
upright
rusted all the way [ __ ] through and
pulled away
and look what they did ah they they put
it together with baling twine why not
it's a republican way america right
america build a wall build a wall bill
[ __ ] bridges [ __ ] bridges build a wall
that they can climb over and come here
maybe we can hire them to [ __ ] repair
a bridge
stupid [ __ ]
yeah i'm [ __ ] pissed off this morning
that's right you guys like angry tony
because i'm [ __ ] pissed that's this
this tweet was from december 28 2018
2018
let's retweet this
go retweet
this [ __ ] picture of this goddamn
upright i think that this picture is way
more significant than the picture of the
bridge collapsing
2018 folks who was the [ __ ] president
who was in charge
who had infrastructure week every
goddamn [ __ ] week in 2018
who who was it
was it a democrat or was it a [ __ ]
fascist who was out [ __ ] golfing
making deals
and and [ __ ] blackmailing people with
russia with russian compromite huh
lindsey graham where the [ __ ] are you
where are you this morning huh
[ __ ]
they're gonna blame oh
brandon's fault brandon's fault oh
brandon's fault that motherfucker's
delivering money to pittsburgh today
ron desantis is down in [ __ ] florida
doing the same goddamn thing taking
credit for the democrats work
after he called it socialism i'll go by
socialism socialism is gonna destroy our
country
you can't you can't go with the joe
biden and the democrats agenda it'll
destroy us
oh here's 80 million dollars that the
democrats passed
even though i fought against it and all
my republican allies fought against it
because we wanted joe biden not to have
a win
because if joe biden has a win that's
bad for us which is bad for america uh
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] all
right let's see if we can find some more
pictures of the underside of this
[ __ ] bridge i think that's the only
one we're gonna see though most of these
pictures
are of the of the collapse
so whatever you do today go spread that
[ __ ] picture around it's on my
timeline now
that we just retweeted go spread this
[ __ ] picture around
take it out
clip it
make your own [ __ ] tweet give the doc
here credit
for the picture
but look at this they're wondering why
the bridge collapsed they're doing an
investigation [ __ ]
you don't need no [ __ ] investigation
i'll tell you why the [ __ ] bridge
collapsed it wasn't even a bridge
it was held together with bailing twine
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] all
right let's go back to the trinity
joining the tree tweets i think that's
about enough of being pissed off about
pittsburgh for now
the pittsburgh bridge
uh this again this bridge is on uh in on
uh in frisk park frick frick park what
the frick
oh [ __ ]
speaking of joe biden in the white house
they got a cat
they got a cat
they got a cat so there's a kitty cat in
the white house
see this is this is what the news should
be right
right this is what we should have the
news be
reuters reports the biden family finally
has a cat first lady jill biden's office
has announced america's first family
is excited to welcome a two-year-old
gray and white stripe feline named
willow to the white house this
this is the news we should have on
friday
not oh my god a [ __ ] bridge fell into
a ravine because republicans had four
years to get their [ __ ] act together
and pass an infrastructure bill they had
infrastructure week every goddamn week
and couldn't get it done
this is the stories
that we should be reporting
this is the [ __ ] that i should be
commenting commenting on making jokes
about
i mean you know there's all kinds of
jokes you can make about this bio or not
but this is the j this is the parody we
should be making fun of
do you follow me
government is hard
policy administration legislation it's
all hard it's really [ __ ] difficult
but the only [ __ ] in this
country that are willing to do it are
people who are pro-democracy and the
only party that's pro-democracy in this
country is democrats the only [ __ ]
ones
they're the only ones that's that's your
choice
you want democracy or you want [ __ ]
lazy ass cheeto dust fascism huh what do
you want
you want ron desantis being lazy yelling
into microphone socialism socialism
socialism joe biden's a socialist
and then when it comes to [ __ ] cash
to check oh yeah i'm gonna give you 80
million bucks ron desantis i'll write it
out on a check right here he'll i'll
sign it i bet that yeah i bet he's got
them big [ __ ] checks you know what
i'm talking about like at the golf
tournaments you know he's passing out
them big [ __ ] checks with his name on
it like trump when he sent the [ __ ]
when he sent the [ __ ] cover checks
you remember that they delayed the
checks because he wanted his [ __ ]
name on it
jesus
whoosh
okay
enough of the cat talk
i'm still pissed off about the [ __ ]
bridge
still [ __ ] livid about the [ __ ]
bridge okay let's go down that dude
let's see what else do we have trending
today we had some other stuff trending
um
we had oh trevor noah's trending that's
a good one south florida that's a
pennsylvania supreme court and
pennsylvania's trending that's another
thing happening in pennsylvania today
act 77 that's the same thing
now the challenger is trending it's the
anniversary of i think the 1986 uh
challenger accident ben carson is
trending because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and so is joe rogan thanks joe rogan is
trending putin thanks joe rogan that's
what i treated earlier thank putin
thanks joe rhoden rogan now joe rogaine
is also trending
because of the spotify thing i can give
my opinion on that i gave my opinion
yesterday
but we'll maybe we'll get in that
in that thread
um for that for that stuff going on over
there
over there's
oh let's see here what else what else do
we get here
what else do we got
um
let's see if we can there's the trevanoa
trend uh you've seen uh
the other day joe rogan here's joe rogan
in the news again
uh and jordan peterson on blackness
they were they're saying [ __ ] about
black and white and oh the only way that
you're really black is if you're from
africa and you're 100 get the [ __ ] out
of here and trevor noah slams dunks
these [ __ ] now here's this clip
and i'll retweet it but i can't play it
because they'll [ __ ] dig me on it i
gotta figure out this fair use thing how
we can combat this when i'm when i'm
going through i'm just reading travis
trevor's [ __ ] tweet here
caitlin says we love pissed off tony
well thank you very much thank you very
much i i like to be twit and mj says
[ __ ] yes we do
i like to get fired up mj says rant on
piss tony is the best
yep
that's what i like to do i like to get
[ __ ] pissed
uh so trevor noah
rebuts this with a video again i'm gonna
retweet his video
but i'm not going to play it because
yeah they'll bang me up even though i'm
supporting trevor here god damn it
trying to play his [ __ ] on the [ __ ] list
roundup
uh but the gist of it is i did watch
this clip earlier because i knew i
wasn't going to be able to play it the
gist of the clip is is that they
black people didn't choose to be called
black
white people call them black
like trevor noah's from africa he's from
south africa but he's not as dark as
dark can be
his mother's white
so he's not he's not black
as joe rogan and jordan peterson would
say it
but he's damn sure black if the cops
pull him over for [ __ ] sure he'd be
black
that's the point he makes in the video
that they don't choose black white or to
be called black
it's a really good video you need to go
watch it i wish i could play it here to
show you
um but hey i get dinged so here's what
would happen is youtube would ding me
and then i'd have to mute that part of
the video so then you wouldn't even hear
the [ __ ] video
so go go to the thread watch the video
enjoy that content because trevor does a
good job of slamming these [ __ ]
now let's see um the act 77 speaking of
uh
pennsylvania the common court of
pennsylvania has found the
commonwealth's no excuse mail and voting
law act 77 is unconstitutional this is
really [ __ ] stupid
this is really [ __ ] stupid now
they're going to go through the appeal
process i'm sure somehow
hopefully
they can get this appealed
this is why we need a voting rights act
this is why we need to codify voting
rights in the united states of america
for all people
this is getting [ __ ] ridiculous
we have we have to
codify voting rights in this country
with the john lewis voting rights act of
the freedom to vote act or whichever act
i'm not opposed to doing a new one hell
call it the freedom american patriot of
voting act i don't give a [ __ ] call
whatever you want call it make america
great again by voting act just [ __ ]
do it
it's enough for this [ __ ] [ __ ]
so they demon unconstitutional to have
no excuse mail in voting so in other
words the only way that is
constitutionally to vote by mail is if
you have an excuse
get the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] pennsylvania has ran like four
elections with this goddamn thing
four
they passed in 2019
breaking court strikes down
pennsylvania's act 777 and voting reform
law passed in 2019 on a bipartisan basis
this was this was before covid they keep
they keep acting like this was done
because of covet because democrats
wanted to cheat this was done before
covid
it's ridiculous
again if you're standing around
wondering cinema and mansion why it's so
important to carve out the filibuster
to make sure
to make sure
that people's voting rights that are
codified in this country
not [ __ ] suppressed which is a
[ __ ] right in the constitution
you would make sure that those people
have those rights
get off your [ __ ] asses
okay
let's see
let's go back to uh trinity trends ben
carson and gives i'm sure just a real
hot take we're 47 minutes into the hour
we're gonna get to the bonehead of the
week real quick here damn
i better get going here son of a [ __ ]
um
we i think we got everything
you do let's let's double check on that
got that got that i think we're ready i
think we're ready for the bonehead of
the week here oh no i got one more one
more thing i gotta add here because we
got you know we we um speaking of bone
of the week we added you know we have a
dishonorable mention every week you guys
know that but we added uh
after last week we coined a new phrase
and we added the uh the alpha cuck of
the week
[Laughter]
you guys remember the alpha cuck noise
yeah so we we added the alpha cuck of
the week
so that's that's going to be in there
too
um
let's see we got some comments here
maybe
uh people talking about voting
uh yoda says my excuse to vote by mail
is that i want to vote without being
around super spreaders you mean like
sarah palin
going out to a restaurant me like that
uh former housing and urban development
secretary
sleepy ben carson i always call joe
biden sleepy but really the name sleepy
should go to ben carson he'd stand up to
my god
like he'd fall asleep like when he was
when he was talking about things
[Music]
he's actually sleepy uh ben carson
remarks on supreme court justice stephen
breyer's rep retirement are being
discussed
carson appeared on wmal
the vincent
something show i don't know i'm not
going to get the name wrong and said
president joe biden was reverting back
to identity politics what
identity politics he [ __ ] promised
[ __ ] we voted for him on this
the country's like oh do we want the guy
who's going to nominate a black woman to
make sure that the court looks like the
country in this diverse are we going to
vote for the cheeto fascist i will go
with the guy who's going to nominate a
black woman on the supreme court to make
sure it looks like the country and it's
diverse like the country
you people really are dumb you are the
ones who are making this about race
joe biden's not making this about race
the simple thing that he's saying is
yeah we should put a black woman on the
court so that way the court looks like
the country instead of a bunch of white
ball sacks up there
white wrinkly old sweaty ball sacks
yeah we don't want that anymore we want
some more diversity from that
[ __ ] ben carson [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] ben carson i'm gonna tweet that
[ __ ] let's tweet that
[ __ ]
ben
arson
that's the tweet yeah
that's
uh what
can't [ __ ] type worth this [ __ ]
that's the tweet [ __ ] men carson that's
the tweet go retweet that [ __ ] there you
go there you go there's your ben carson
tweet [ __ ] that guy all right let's go
back to the trendy trends here because
we have some things to get to before we
get to the bonehead and we're at 50
minutes into the first hour holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] okay let's see here
of course ukrainian president's still
trending let's go to the 4u
susan collins trending again looks like
ron desantis is trending oh yeah that's
what we want
there's where we want this is it this is
it ron desantis you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] look at this guy 24 minutes he went
on and on and on about how he was go it
was he was giving 80 million dollars of
infrastructure money ron desantis is
awarding over 80 million dollars for
infrastructure projects in south florida
and south floridians aren't buying it
don't [ __ ] gaslight these
[ __ ] south floridians are
smarter than this to know that ron
desantis isn't awarding this money
he's the one who was fighting against it
calling it socialism he didn't want you
to have the [ __ ] money
the [ __ ] out of here this is more of
this pittsburgh bridge type [ __ ]
pisses me the [ __ ] off
your tweet sucks ron it [ __ ] sucks
and you suck too
you piece of [ __ ]
your tweet sucks look at see twitter
look at this every [ __ ] time
have we still figured out what is it the
sucks is it the sucks word or is it the
[ __ ] word
maybe i should put like a an
uh
an exclamation mark here for [ __ ] to see
if that changes things
like see if they still [ __ ] say oh
you can't tweet this because it's
offensive they say offensive offensively
potentially harmful
i actually like that more that it's
potentially harmful
potentially harmful
i mean potentially harmful i'm just
telling the [ __ ] truth
it's the sucks word mj says you think
it's a sucks word
anonymous says [ __ ] ron desantis that
prick has blood on his hands you goddamn
right he does
um
mj says perfect alpha cuck wannabe
dictator oh and you think that might be
the alpha cuck well we'll see who the
alpha cuck is
we'll see who the alpha cuck is
[Laughter]
robin says don't forget to hit the
thumbs up thanks for reminding me robin
welcome we're glad to have you here
every day robin we love having you here
uh midas robin she's part of the midas
mighty that comes over
our our audience is cross paths a lot so
thanks thanks for reminding about the
thumbs up uh
of course i want to tweet this twitter
why the [ __ ] what i want to tweet it
every day stop asking me that [ __ ] well
speaking of minus what does minus touch
say here this money came from president
biden's infrastructure bill which ron
desantis opposed not only did he [ __ ]
oppose it he was like ah socialism it's
gonna destroy our country
we're gonna head down the road of
socialism they're going to take your
kids and your guns and blab to blab the
[ __ ]
that's that's what it sounds like when
they talk about that [ __ ]
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
okay let's go back to this uh let's see
there's got to be some good [ __ ]
jokes in here where are they where are
they i know everyone's got their [ __ ]
ron desantis
uh
tweet out this morning
come on there's gotta be something here
filling up these filling up with news we
don't want to fill the tweet the trends
up with news
we want jokes
we want jokes
we want jokes
and not [ __ ] rhonda santa's fluffers
here
they're all in here fluffing rhonda
saints oh he's so great he gave us money
yeah the only reason why he was able to
give you money
is because
of the [ __ ] because of the [ __ ]
the democrats they're the only ones that
deliver anything infrastructure money
education
health care you want it they ain't got
it oh mj says uh the podcast upgrade
fund you're already reminding me yeah
i'll remind everybody about the podcast
up for grade fun you guys can go to d
tonymichaels.com
and at the very top of the page is the
podcast upgrade fun if you guys like to
contribute to the podcast here since
we're doing two hours every single day
every single weekday
it does cost a little bit more money
because you know what you know what's uh
exciting about having two hours a day is
it gets on the podcast directories
every single day so like before
the [ __ ] list roundup was on youtube uh
when i would post it and then twitter
twitch live but now it's live across
youtube and twitter twitch but also it's
on every single day on your podcast
directories uh you know apple spotify
who everyone's pissed off at spotify
let's you know now that we're talking
about that now that we're talking about
that
just
let's let's talk about spotify for a
second um the joe rogaine
um thread was trending but we we can
just talk about it we ain't gonna have
it we ain't gotta have a [ __ ]
before we get a bonehead here
so spotify
and i talked about this a little bit
yesterday right neil young um protesting
by saying pull my music down if you're
gonna continue with joe rogan which is
his which is
neil young's complete right
and to some degree i think neil young is
right if he doesn't want his [ __ ]
music on a platform that joe rogan's on
he should not have it on a platform that
joe rogan's on it's his [ __ ] music
and if his fans don't want to download
his music that's fine too now everyone's
down uh deleting the the spotify app and
talking about how it takes 12 steps to
delete the app or some [ __ ] or delete
their account and there's premium
spotify and all this [ __ ] now if you're
paying for spotify and don't want to pay
for it anymore fine great don't pay for
spotify anymore fantastic but here's the
thing
here's the thing if if everyone
including me leaves spotify then that
leaves joe rogan over there
whether i'm there or not joe rogan's
gonna be there he's got a hundred
million dollar contract and there's a
reason why spotify paid a hundred
million dollars for joe rogan
it's because like eight million people
listen eight to ten million people
listen to that [ __ ]
boneheads listen to that son of a [ __ ]
so you want to show spotify if you want
to really get to spotify
and you really want to show them what to
do with their business model
what you need to do
is to go to spotify and download every
single [ __ ] thing that is not rogan
that isn't rogan go download it download
the [ __ ] out of it comment [ __ ] give
it five stars
if it rebuts rogan anything that's on
there like my voice that that tries to
tackle that [ __ ] go give it five
stars give it a good review
do all that stuff
not not delete the app and let the 8
million people still listen to joe rogan
because as long as 8 to 10 million still
listen to joe rogan and spotify has
monetary monetary reasons to do it
they're gonna do it they're going to
it's gonna happen
you're not gonna stop spotify from
making money
not not a hundred million worth of money
especially when eight to ten million
dollars or eight to ten million people
look
and listen to that son of a [ __ ] every
single day
so you want to combat it go support the
content that combats it
that's what you should do get your
friends your neighbors introduce them to
the content i'm not saying pump my
content there's plenty of content out
there that's anti-rogan that's opposite
of what rogan meaning like telling truth
and facts and [ __ ] not lying to [ __ ]
people and spreading misinformation that
kills people gets people sick continues
to [ __ ] hurt our economy this is not
this coveted running around
and our hospitals being full and the
schools being out is not good for our
[ __ ] economy
god damn there's businesses closing up
closing up restaurants closing up
because they can't keep open because
their [ __ ] employees are sick
they're [ __ ] sick do you get it
they're [ __ ] sick
because you people are [ __ ] running
around spreading this [ __ ] because you
won't get do a simple thing and get
vaccinated you're spending too much time
[ __ ] eating dirt from canada taking
baths and borax drinking your own
[ __ ] piss and then gobbling down
horse paste
spending all this time and energy to get
rid and not have coveted when you could
just do the simple thing go get [ __ ]
vaccinated
then they yell and scream about
monocolonial [ __ ] antibodies and [ __ ]
regeneron releases a statement
regeneron's like yeah our thing does not
help
with the [ __ ] variant the omicron i
call it the [ __ ] variant because it has
clearly become the [ __ ] variant just
like i predicted
the [ __ ] morons are spreading it
around the [ __ ] country
now i'm not saying that everyone oh well
tony people who are vaccinated are
getting it yeah yeah there's
breakthrough but that's the whole point
of getting everyone vaccinated the more
vaccinated the less breakthrough
it's a [ __ ] amazing how numbers work
it's [ __ ] amazing how statistics and
numbers work i don't throw them at you
guys because i don't think i need to
because i think you guys are [ __ ]
smart enough to understand that [ __ ]
but some of them are not
oh
well we're gonna get bonehead going here
soon
let's get let's get back see if we uh
let's see what else did we miss in the
[ __ ] list here
uh
south florida
[Music]
i feel like there's something i'm
missing
i wonder what it is maybe i had a uh
maybe i had a bookmark that i wanted to
uh speak about
i had something i had something in mind
but it just is not coming to me
you know you get on these tangents and
[ __ ] let's see what other
oh shapiro
is this ben shapiro is he trending of
course he is
of course he is who who wants who wants
to dig on shapiro here we're we're one
hour in let's take a break we'll come
back
uh we'll we'll dig on shapiro uh right
after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast and the shitless
roundup
we're waiting for uh gabe to join us for
the bonehead of the week until that time
i think we're gonna dig on ben shapiro
here who wants to go after ben shapiro
uh we were just talking about uh cove
and that's probably what this guy's
talking about i don't know maybe
this guy you never know what this [ __ ]
what what what is ben shapiro saying
that everyone's tweeting about does
anyone know
anyone know why he's trending there's
probably a hundred different things
a hundred different things
that he's training for i mean of course
he trends because he's a dumbass in my
mind
this is the best ben shapiro video ever
okay well i'm i'm willing to play ball
here i think i've seen this one before
but i'm willing to play ball let's make
this bigger so you can see it
let's see let's go ahead and play this
the water levels around the world rise
by by let's say five feet yeah five feet
next hundred years ten feet by the next
hundred years and it puts all the
low-lying areas on the coast underwater
right yep right which let's say all of
that happens you think that people
aren't going to just sell their homes
and move
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh my god so here's ben shapiro's theory
right this is the theory here that he's
that he's pushing and these people in
the room are like oh he's really smart
he's so smart he's so [ __ ] smart
here's the theories okay so five feet of
water gets in the in your house right
all right
and then ben shapiro thinks that the
real estate value is still there like
you're like oh well [ __ ] i'll just put a
[ __ ] floating for sale sign out in
the floating out in the [ __ ] swimming
pool of the front yard and you know
someone will surely come along in a row
boat and be like oh you want you want a
half a million dollars for this house
abso [ __ ] lutely i don't see anything
wrong with it
it's not real estate anymore if it's
permanently under five feet of water you
dumb [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yes kaelin harvard isn't giving
us their best lately
um
of course you know ben shapiro claims to
be some kind of [ __ ] smart guy you
know he went to school and all this [ __ ]
and you know what's funny about that is
all these [ __ ] [ __ ] out there
that listen to this [ __ ] puke they're
like oh all these elites you know who's
never worked day in their life never
swung a hammer i know these
[ __ ] like i know them i've
talked to people personally who listen
to this dumb [ __ ] that i know
that are firefighters and carpenters i'm
like you realize that this dumb
[ __ ] has never done anything for
himself ever
ever like swinging a hammer or fighting
fires are working in a nine-to-five job
ever he knows nothing about you and
gives not a [ __ ] about you
now robin says i can't stand this punk
yeah [ __ ] him and mj says harvard has no
standards obviously
obviously
it's an obvious problem that we have oh
[ __ ] let's see what do we got
okay all right all right gabe gabe's
gabe's going to join us here in just a
minute uh so let's let's continue with
the uh
let's give credit here i gotta give
credit
it's one of the best
ben shapiro clips of all time
um
in my mind says i think it is i think it
is it's a very it's a very popular
famous um um
clip
let's see what what's going on here
um oh look look who decided to join us
look who's here
howdy gabe
what's up how's it going
yeah we're we're just trashing on ben
shapiro he's trending for some reason
i'm not sure why
uh actually uh
what is it i bet ben shapiro's with us
folks uh uh uh uh uh actually uh uh it's
it's uh it's a plywood uh and i put in a
bag
no no it's poplar yeah yeah that's right
i should know that because i did the
very it's popular this beautiful this
beautiful piece of poplar
wood i'm the i'm the proud owner of this
popular one
that's what he said
he's never he's never held a piece of
wood in his life and i'm not just
talking about lumber i'm talking about
another stuff
the video i did he's like wow so this is
what hardwood looks like
oh you did it i did a walking run about
ben shapiro
i did a video i called him little boy
lumber little i think that's a that
sounds like uh you know what maybe he
should go into the ensemble or the alpha
cox well
i i think i think that's
alphacut.com maybe that's his maybe
that's his uh profile handle on
alphabets.com we're trying to figure out
everyone i don't know if everyone knows
this but we bought alpha cux what you
bought you bought it yeah i bought
alphago live on the show last week yeah
and and we we've actually tried to make
we're going to make it part of the
of the show so yeah
yeah well no i we have one for today's
show
well that i think and so we're today is
the premiere of
of
alpha cox
should we switch to to the bone hand of
the week here yeah the switch here we go
we're in the bonehead of the week here
now um so let's let's play the music and
then we'll start
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the latest edition of bone
hint of the week
thank you for joining us here
i like i i i always get excited about
the music don't you yeah like it's just
it's still puts a little pep
pep in my step you know right maybe that
should be like the background on on
alphacuts.com
maybe maybe we should do like an
alphacuts.com commercial that we could
play on oh yeah that would be great like
a dating site
do you think you're too alpha for others
do you feel like you're um you're on top
of all the betas
on top of yeah exactly
someone write this [ __ ] down so we can
so we can make this commercial i i like
it now speaking of commercials um not to
go into the interview too much but you
and missy uh modell who is our interview
on monday we're gonna play that on
monday you guys have some exciting news
about a commercial right yeah we've got
uh uh for a little preview for people
we've got a commercial uh it's about
face masks okay face masks and it's a
it's it's targeted for the people who
have uh
uh
and are unable
to wear the face mask properly right so
it's called the droop you know droop
yeah it's for the people who just let it
sag oh okay so saggy mass syndrome yeah
exactly
so yeah it's a it's a commercial for
that and so yeah just putting it
together and uh
um
we'll uh we'll have it we'll have it on
the show on monday uh i might release it
this weekend if i have time okay good
good yeah yeah we'll play it we'll play
it on monday uh yeah maybe but it'll be
in the rotation of commercials now
yeah so so we'll put it in the rotation
i i had to fix one i kept i kept playing
the sound that the show's on wednesday
so i had
well yeah yeah you know you know it's
every day man every single day eastern
11 central right here on youtube twitter
twitch yeah on the west coast it's 9am
right right right it depends on where
you're at in the country morning
afternoon lunch time you know so here's
our here's our contestant oh here's our
contestants this week
now we had peter ducey douchey i guess
we could go on yeah uh rep jim banks and
donald trump jr now we've had a lot of
[ __ ] boneheads in the meantime with
these with these with these [ __ ] oh
yeah but the but the one peter ducey of
course if we go there first um and we
can probably play the uh the video let's
go
let's go let's go dc
i i thought that was a good one let's go
dc i thought it was a good one um but
biden um ducey asked biden in like a
press conference thing about inflation a
really it really is kind of a stupid
question it really was i mean as he was
also as was it while he was being
removed like everyone's like okay
everyone well they were they were
ushering the the uh the press out the
press questions had stopped um and he
was still ducey was still you know like
most press does yells as they leave the
room to try to see if they can get the
president to respond right and their
president responds by leaning into the
mic and he's like
what a stupid son of a [ __ ]
and i got the clip here let's let's see
if we can we can play the the clip josh
jordan has it here let's retweet this
and give him some bonehead credit here
um
thanks for being on the bone end of the
week
uh let's see here
let's uh
this one has nine and a half million
views holy [ __ ] that's how many people
want to see and i also want to point out
that
uh ducey did interviews with fox after
this happened and they were also
they were kind of ragging on ducey as
well right like it is a dumb question
what is it yeah yeah but i was like oh
look at that you've got both the left
and the right who are like yeah i do see
you're [ __ ] dumb
and then he just stands there and he's
like
yep yep
well and i i love that the one interview
that he did
he's like the president the president
called me personally and said it was not
personal pal
yeah topper you're just a dumb buck it's
not anything personal yeah it's just
stupid it's like that was just a dumb
dumb thing that's a really stupid
question it's like every day he's like
every day i watch you
ask the same dumb [ __ ] questions
right right well and he finally and
again you know my biden doesn't like
cover the mic or he doesn't like move
over to the side yeah he like leans in
let's watch those watch
so they're being ushered out here
of course everyone's kind of yelling a
question and if you listen carefully
[Music]
[Laughter]
i actually love this and i hate that he
apologized i think what he should have
done is say i'm not apologizing it was a
stupid question he is a stupid son of a
[ __ ] we're asking it like what's so you
know the let's go brandon crowd loses
their [ __ ] minds right over this clip
of him of him saying stupid son of a
[ __ ] and really honestly um some people
were saying in like the deep dark you
know alpha cuck part of the web they
were like oh finally joe biden [ __ ]
is is tough and you know all this [ __ ]
he's willing to say you know because
that's what they loved about trump the
most right yeah they didn't stand in
front of a microphone and he would just
tell it like it is he would say whatever
yeah right right whatever cuss word came
to his mind he'd say you know they they
like that [ __ ] these these [ __ ] alpha
cucks they like that kind of [ __ ] this
you know this this uh uh
masculinity or you know mcchismo yeah
macho man type [ __ ] and they say right
and they see joe biden as saying calling
him a stupid son of a [ __ ]
but here's the thing all those dudes
those like real the realities they live
in when they're like oh yeah [ __ ] you
man you know what they only happen in
here they never actually come out right
right and if they do
then
typically i've seen obviously hey you
took an action and said that and the
consequences you just got your ass beat
right right right
and that's just the reality i i know i
know well the so so this is why ducey
became the um the bonehead or was on the
bonehead of the week he was not the
winner um
he was pretty close
uh at the beginning it seemed like a
close race right right i mean him and
jim banks now
as we're sitting here it's even hard for
me to even recall what jim banks did at
this point the rep from indiana right so
let's
just look up what jim banks did go ahead
there was another because there were a
couple things that happened there was
one thing that happened earlier this
week and then he had another one oh he's
seeking a fourth term go [ __ ] himself
uh he announced that he was 22 hours ago
he's announced that he's running for
re-election
uh
oh oh it's because he did a thing he's
like has anyone ever um
this is it right here right yeah the
whole like has anyone ever seen a
president attacked attack the fair and
free media or whatever was let's let's
let's go to this let me go back all
right here we are here's the um
uh joe i actually tweeted this earlier
this week we tweeted this earlier this
week she said
the yam she said tented but i think yam
titted yeah
yam tinted turd attacked the free free
press more than two thousand times via
tweet alone jim banks is not a serious
person he's really not um but this is
this is the screenshot of the tweet
that is this this is the one that we put
him on the bone yeah yeah that's not
another bone-headed [ __ ] since then but
yeah yeah
uh i mean okay let's just let's just
clarify some things here right because
obviously this is this is connected to
ducey however
um
have we ever seen a president attack
yeah remember when donald trump made fun
of the disabled reporter that was that
was just one example of [ __ ] gross by
the way right
uh and then uh biden
just keep in mind body did not attack
the free press
okay he just called ducey a stupid son
of a [ __ ] right
uh is that what he's talking about i
mean is that yeah that's what he's
talking about yeah this is in relation
to ducey so this is like right after he
was like oh what the hell have you ever
seen the president attack
and moline the free press like joe
barton has that's what that's what the
country is
depending on minnie mouse's pants
exactly that's the outrage you're like
if i'm not coming over green m m's or
not you know
[ __ ] taking advantage of a minnie
mouse doll then i'm you know uh going
after the president for saying what a
stupid son of a [ __ ]
it's not an attack he just said it right
it was just like a statement he wasn't
saying like
something i you know i don't know i
think i mean like it's nothing in
comparison it was hard it was hard it
was hard to hear in the video that we
showed what ducey said but ducey
essentially said yes
is good is it good politically is it is
it a liability for inflation it's a
political liability and that's when you
hear biden say no it's an asset you know
like you dumb [ __ ] and he's
lucky he didn't say that into the mic
he's lucky he just called him because i
would have said you dumb [ __ ] i
mean that's what i said right
but it's like also let's remember that
when uh
when trump also said in a tweet it
wasn't you know wasn't the media but he
also said to get that dumb was it that
dumb son of a [ __ ] and he was talking
about kaepernick
son of a [ __ ] off the field i mean
trump you son of a [ __ ] all the time
right yeah and someone someone posted a
video of all the times that he had said
oh it might have been it might have been
wu-tang yeah there was there there were
several of them not just him saying son
of a [ __ ] but also you know we're just
attacking yeah yeah right just cursing
and being [ __ ] it is great that when
something happens they're like oh what
and then you're like yo look at this
evidence of this clap
[Music]
and when they lose their [ __ ] you
know this is the alpha cook [ __ ] right
this is the alpha good [ __ ] so so jim
banks um
it was pretty goddamn close right um
yeah in the beginning it was close i
mean it was close between him and uh
peter ducey it was right
junior kind of you know kind of uh
pulled ahead in the beginning
but i mean and he stayed ahead for a
while and then he kind of inched forward
but i'm not going to say my i'm not
going to say my video helped it but you
know
push push don jr
gave him the edge is that what you're
saying speaking of videos you know we uh
we watched and you said about the green
m ms and we'll probably get to that when
we get to the alpha cuck um maybe we'll
play uh some video that i found on the
internet they've
it's it's i think it's a kitkat bar and
uh green m m and a bar oh yeah they're
having drinks yeah oh so maybe we played
it earlier i found it you know in some
obscure thread yeah it wasn't like an it
was like an alpha [ __ ] forum yeah i
think it wasn't alpha club forum is
where we found it you know it was like
uh it was like a
you know like a cell phone video or
something like that okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah so uh
speaking speaking of uh
alpha cucks and and our are not not our
winner but we also have a dishonorable
mention this week now we have matt gatz
the pedo mat game and really the reason
why he's on here is because of the new
news about ellicott yeah do you remember
this news from earlier in the week even
though we've had like
thirty thousand news since i know i just
the i can't keep up with the simulation
um
uh we had him on last week
and yeah he was he was actually in the
running right he was saying he was in
the running last week because he it was
that first day it was monday i think or
sunday or monday there was mention of
his ex-girlfriend
uh cooperating with the fbi which is
like that's a pretty big thing
especially because she was granted
immunity and it's like okay that's
that's and that and that's what everyone
presumed has been taking so long right
because that immunity would take a long
time to obtain they just like wouldn't
handle like that's a unicorn in federal
prosecution yeah yeah like they don't
just give [ __ ] immunity to anybody
right you got to have something some
something real it's like you can like
hang on to and i think and i i i would
imagine for a lot of people who are like
oh when is when is he gonna get you know
like rated or like when he's gonna get
arrested and take it in and you know all
the stuff
uh and i think for something like this
like again just like january 6 you've
got to make sure that you have your like
your ducks in a row right you got to
make sure that you've got them lined up
so that when you do in fact take this
person or group to court that you do not
have any flaw or any shadow of a doubt
in the case because what's going to
happen is if you go in and say
this guy was a part of a sex trafficking
ring and was making false identification
documents and and this and that like
yeah we've got some evidence here and
there but you better make sure that
you've got that stuff lined up because
if you don't
they're going to poke holes in it and
that person is going to walk and then
you can't come back and get them again
unless some new evidence comes out well
and and the prosecutors in our
misogynistic culture and in the reality
of of our misogynistic culture um
they have two star witnesses here it
appears to be joel greenberg and the the
ex-girlfriend obstruction of justice
right but also witness in the um one of
the women that was underage when they
trafficked her um and she became i guess
in the porn star afterwards which of
course the prosecutors and the jury are
going to make her the you know heard the
[ __ ] her the criminal and all this
[ __ ] you know right that's what that's
what of course yeah let's let's culture
let's blame the woman for right we can't
trust her we can't trust her with her
story because she might have been a porn
star and she might have made some bad
decisions so her story doesn't count or
matter so that's that's i believe um you
know for good bad or worse i think it's
really ridiculous that our culture does
this um to the [ __ ] victim she's a
[ __ ] victim right here let's gaslight
her and say no no it's because you're a
porn so it's like whether that was out
of her own decision or a a byproduct or
result of the environment that she was
in or the experience that she had right
there's nothing wrong with being a
friend
you know this is this is the [ __ ]
eminem minnie mouse [ __ ] what the hell
if a woman wants to be a porn star let
her be a porn star as long as she's of
age and she can consent what the sex
work is work and i guess
two things to remember one that person
probably didn't even want to be with you
unless you're gonna pay for that right
right and two
there's someone else they're somewhere
else you you do not interact with that
person your lives do not cross over
unless you're actively going to their
website to look at their stuff right
right josh holly right just name
just
did i i mean yeah no i yeah yeah well so
this ellicott let's let's pull up the um
the ellicott article here frank's got it
here uh his client has been cooperating
in the sex trafficking case against getz
florida shock jock joe ellicott and matt
gatt's
circle please guilty so this one is
really unique here's why it's unique
normally what happens in a federal court
and we've seen this time and time again
even with like joel greenberg a grand
jury
prosecutors normally convene a grand
jury the u.s attorney can means a grand
jury for the for the prosecutors to
present their case for indictment the
grand jury would normally seal or
release an indictment and then those
whoever's in the indictment would be
arraigned of those charges right just
like joe greenberg was this guy was not
given a grand jury indictment that is
significant and the reason why that's
significant in my opinion is that and
i'm not a lawyer but
i i think it's significant in that
they
knew that this guy had receipts right
they could have taken this to the grand
jury but they let this guy plead to some
some drug charges and some mail fraud
charges um basically getting him away
from sex trafficking so that way he
could provide receipts he would come and
he would plead guilty to these charges
in open court
but without a grand jury indictment and
then
then what he would do
is because he's not charged by that
grand jury he can go testify and be
deposed by the grand jury in the sex
trafficking part of the case because
apparently um this guy not only was
dealing adderall but he was dealing it
to people through venmo and matt gas
matt gas was made several appearances on
his venmo the other thing that's
significant is this guy this ellicott is
apparently a witness to not only joel
greenberg talking about having sex and
trafficking underage women but also
being in the room when matt gatz and
joel greenberg was in the room with him
that is a story that's being told now so
i believe that in our misogynistic
culture this is a is the the the ace in
the hole i think that the prosecutors
wanted yeah where they have someone
who's you know white and a male but
[ __ ] ridiculous and who isn't the
victim who can tell their story right um
and and a jury believe it it's
ridiculous that we still
have to do these things these gymnastics
in this culture right it is a thing it
is a thing that has to be done and it's
ridiculous because sex work is working
we shouldn't shame a woman especially
because that's her job so this is the
reason why matt getz
made the dishonorable mention this week
um
and uh you know i i think he's gonna
make this honorable mention and probably
bone of the week several times in the
next few months i'm honestly waiting for
the i'm waiting for them because we
talked about this last time it's like i
don't know what's gonna happen first
like is the hubris is the hubris too big
where he's going to stay
and not resign up until the like he's
going to just yeah and
keep in mind like the midterms are all
the way in november but he's got to
start campaigning soon
for re-election
so
because his his seat is up in 2023 so
you look at that and you're like either
he
doesn't
uh doesn't think that he will um
go down and he thinks he's like
invincible because of
you know that's the type of stuff that
you know when he got duis his dad was
the one who got him out of those
situations right so you know he's like
what's gonna happen now
uh is is comes down to
whether he's going to resign like when
the like the letter resignation gets
sent off as soon as the fbi [ __ ]
raids the house
or
he says screw it and i'm going to
continue to uh represent myself in the
public eye as
uh as someone who did nothing wrong
right mj here says she doesn't think
you'll resign yeah and i don't either
either way it it's gonna be hilarious
and i have my popcorn ready to go
well and and you you posted your uh matt
gets goes the hell
video the other day you know i do have
another idea for one about venmo uh oh
really yeah yeah we should do like a uh
um not venmo commercial but like a a
cash app like a republican cash you know
like the baby you have the maga maybe
you should do like uh that's not let me
do like a mob
a maga
cash app type um like a payment
processor yeah payment process a maga
payment processing
uh parity
payment processing parity you know
that's a lot of payments
okay yeah yeah republican payment
processing period
yeah except it'll be like cash spelled
with a k
right uh maybe three days yeah
collective cash
so yeah there you go there you go
collective cash uh i don't know what the
third one is yeah yeah we'll come up
with something good yeah that's that's
great yeah oh oh yoda here look look
look see they're giving it ben gets
the gats app i don't know yeah he said
he look it he literally tweeted he said
i he he tweeted that he wanted
uh a gates gate to happen
and if oh
maddie did yeah yeah and so it's like
one of those things like oh put it on
the vision board and he did it like he
was the one
who literally put it out there into the
ether and then it it literally became a
thing so
i mean he can't blame anyone but himself
you know why i mean a lot of these are
like caitlyn says ken paxton you know
this is the guy in texas and the
attorney oh the one that won it again
yeah there's all kinds of [ __ ] is that
the one that was that's the same guy
that was like i'll give a million dollar
prize if anyone can show her like a
reward
he says a lot of [ __ ] right but then who
was it in in pubs yeah it was better it
was fun right right and he's like yo
where's my money right i want my [ __ ]
i want my billion bucks [ __ ] i think he
was gonna donate it too too yeah
something like parent plan but of course
they're like oh i didn't mean it i was
just kidding i was being sarcastic and
it's like where are you though you want
to hear here caitlyn says he's under
indictment for five crimes and growing
that's uh oh
just a how am i not surprised it's a
couple of times maybe maybe we can tie a
couple more republicans into this um
right this cur maybe it's called the
corrupt cash collection oh there you go
corrupt cash collection i'm just we're
just snowballing yeah that's how these
videos are made folks as we yeah yeah we
just we just start to snowball there we
go
yeah yeah okay well um so so i want to
move on before we get to our winner here
because um last week
last week we coined a phrase here on the
bonehead of the week alpha cuck um can
you explain to the audience what alpha
cuck is exactly and how that how that
came to be yeah so alpha cux are uh
are are the um
wannabe alphas
the the boys who claim to be the man's
man
the ones who
uh
uh are you know they're just in cells
the ones who uh try to make themselves
appear like they're macho they're the
only they are the alpha now keep in mind
when you are in alpha there can only be
one so everyone else is betas right and
the alpha doesn't have to say they're
now but like right the alpha is just
like he just walks in and everyone's
like oh [ __ ] that's the alpha all these
other guys are like i'm an alpha and i'm
going to alphacon which is a real thing
by the way
uh there is a convention held for alphas
so at this convention
they're all alphas right they're all
about this there's no there's one alpha
and they're all betas so alphacut is um
is yeah is the uh they they pretend to
be alphas and
they're just a bunch of [ __ ] cucks
and i don't know
and i just kind of said it i just like
it just came out it didn't come out it
felt right
we were watching a video about uh ethan
schmidt the guy who goes right yeah
people with camper
is harassing people and he got owned by
the kid and that's when it came out i
was like
right yeah yeah it's perfect and then we
rolled with it so this now we have a new
segment we have a new segment on the
bonehead of the week here and it is
called applica and guess
guess who is the very first alka-cuck on
bonehead of the week none other than
tucker carlson i believe he's been the
bone end of the week a couple times
hasn't yeah i think he's actually been
the bonehead of several times i don't
know i it's hard to keep track we've
done this for a couple months now yeah
do it every week it's it's pretty crazy
to think back and be like oh when did we
start this you know like yeah right well
yeah it was it was it was a long time
ago
actually let's do this let's plug the
poll if you if you want to vote on the
bonehead of the week polo go to at
tonymichaelspod also follow me
tonymichaels and follow gabe i am gabe
sanchez so go go follow us there and
you'll you'll see the poll every week
we kind of wait a little bit now that we
do this on friday we want to release it
on monday or tuesday but
the problem is we have so many [ __ ]
boneheads that pile up that's why the
dishonorable mention became came about
right because we had so many like by the
time the news got to the time we'd do
the episode and the poll was done yeah
we're like well [ __ ] there's like 14
other bone-ins that we can talk about
exactly that's where the dishonorable
mention came in because i think that was
in what this third or fourth episode of
the bonehead of the week i think yeah
yeah we started to notice that it was
like oh we can't keep up and then uh we
just needed to add a throw another one
in there yeah so now that we're on the
second hour uh every friday we got
plenty of time we figured well let's do
the alpha cup all right we got now we
got not only the the three that you vote
on for the official bone in the week but
also the alpha kicks um speaking of um
uh tucker and alpha cux i i'm on the
tucker eminem thread here
uh because i i think this is why he
ended up as the the alpha cuck is the
problem yeah his
uh the problem that he has with m m's
right his obsession with the green
eminem
right i mean candace owens had you know
it was in a pant suit did you see that
she was in a [ __ ] pant suit on on
[ __ ] waters show bitching about
minnie mouse being drawn in a pant suit
i'm like what are you talking about
you're wearing one yeah it was the funny
part is they were both purple too
minnie's was purple it was it's fine
what i find funny about it is that is
that uh candace owens in that segment
talks about how this is some big
distraction in it from from buying's
like like that there's like some global
conspiracy that biden controls
international companies to make
decisions
to make them more woke to distract them
or distract everyone else from american
issues when it's like
so now he does have a bunch of power to
control things but then you literally
just said a few weeks ago if not a month
ago
that biden
wasn't doing anything he didn't have any
control and he couldn't change things
like
gasoline prices so it's like pick one or
the other he's either having a global
conspiracy and he's in control like it's
some cabal like deep state thing like
some people claim
and and somehow isn't using that power
to influence other things but he's only
doing it to influence the companies and
making their
statements
well i mean i i can't i can't i can't
even understand how they went down this
road with this minnie mouse thing
because it's one drawing of her and it's
like it's not it's it's for like paris
and i think that's where the world
conspiracy comes in i guess but it's
like a special thing and they did the
one drawing i mean it's not like minnie
mouse has never appeared in different
[ __ ] outfits before and it's a
cartoon it's a [ __ ] cartoon
and literally literally bridges are
falling down in pittsburgh this morning
right and these people's number one
issue and she says it in that clip let's
let's make let's make
minnie mouse the number one issue like
you that's okay whatever so so this is
video i found earlier
and then really obscure alphacut thread
i think
and i don't know this it says green
eminem and it looks this person kind of
looks familiar to me i'm not sure who
this is
um i mean the m m's kind of look look
like each other you think so like
they're familiar okay let's let's see
let's see what the green eminem it looks
like
she may have a drinker and let's see
what what's going on in this video
tucker was fine at first but then he
went all psycho on me how do you mean
well for starters he would text me
non-stop while i was on set ooh red flag
he became obsessive demanding to see my
emails where i was going who i was with
double red flag then he would text me
ideas about changing my looks that i
would be sweeter if i were white
chocolate they aren't even chocolate
just sugar and bland vanilla hey
all chocolates matter buckley shut up
and remember when i started wearing
sneakers because i kept losing my go-go
boots yeah
it turns out tucker was stealing them
filling them with chocolate and then
he was speaking russian while doing it
in front of a bed full of minnie mouse
styles and mr potato heads ugh he's just
like matt gates and then he showed up to
my house at three in the morning with
the boombox reenacting the scene from
say anything so what did you do i filed
a restraining order and then he told me
you'll regret the day you were coded
what does that even mean he'll probably
say something dumb on his energy is
unappealing and totally androgynous
until the moment you wouldn't want to
have a drink with any one of them that's
the goal when you're totally turned off
we've achieved equity
tucker was
so i don't i don't know i'm not sure
um
apparently tucker might hang out there
too so you want to avoid he also might
be he might be 86 from that bar if i if
i were to assume he probably is not
allowed there anymore
um but tucker is that type of dude that
would like you know i don't know i mean
like when when i was writing i was like
oh what the [ __ ] can he do i was like
i'm gonna make this [ __ ] weird it's
already weird to start with he's already
talking about being attracted or not
attracted to the m m's these inanimate
objects they have this crazy fascination
with
uh oh thank you mj um they have this
crazy fascination and they being the
republicans are right wing uh
fascination with
the genitals or the private parts of an
inanimate object well they're they're
they're toys
but they're completely deceptive with
everyone's genitals these are weird
[ __ ] like you remember the
bathroom thing that we had to go through
like for a whole year it was this you
know it's the same thing as the crt it
was the bathroom voodoo right which
turned out not to it's like not a thing
right right it's not most people don't
go in the bathroom and think about other
people's genitals right in the back or
people or the other thing is people do
not go through a transition
from uh male to female female to male
for the opportunity to then take
advantage it's not going to go through
years of transitioning with hormones and
treatments to this to then say like it
was all worth it to just molest this
person in the bathroom that's not a
thing that does not happen right any
claim you want to make about that is you
might want to research because i even
think joe uh no who uh
i
forgot what i was watching the other day
somebody tried to do it and they got
fact-checked in real time to say like oh
it was the [ __ ] hassan and it was uh
christian walker and christian walker
made this claim and he's like okay oh
yeah yeah and then somebody remember you
said that was that was on his uh his
twitch yeah yeah and somebody fact
checked him in real time and brought up
the article and then they read it and it
was like oh this is actually nothing
like what the claim was you know the
person wasn't doing that the person
there was some policy that wasn't
enacted there were all these different
things
in there
uh that that were debunked the claim
that this was all intentionally done
um
uh for the purpose of transitioning to
then take advantage of someone in about
speaking of transitioning in bathrooms
and genitals this is what this is about
this is this white fragility fear that
they would go to a bar and pick up on a
woman a beautiful woman they think is
sexy and you know that they might want
to have sex with and they go home and
then their fear is they get there and
find out that
either this woman has a penis or they
used to be a man and they have this huge
fear like it's this am i gay i you know
this insecurity about their sexuality
god forbid they're just attracted to the
person as they are like yeah obviously
looks and whatnot but like if that's
what you like then that's what you like
but if you show up to the house and
you're surprised and it's like i don't
know maybe that tells more about you
than it does about them right
caitlin says tuckums makes me drier than
ben shapiro's boy
oh god
i i'm sorry i'm sure i got distracted
but but here's the thing on this on this
with the transition thing because that's
what this eminem thing's about don't get
it skewed everyone thinks that it's some
kind of weird [ __ ] fetish that that
tucker has it's not he was coaxed into
doing this [ __ ] on live on air and it's
this trend is just transphobia [ __ ]
because listen listen to the words he
uses when he talks about um and and
what's crazy here let me move the
[ __ ] banner here
is the words at the bottom candy and
sexy shoes is highly offensive right
right so like that's
no right but there's entertainment info
for him but they're doing two different
things here they're saying the left is
trying to cancel and they're also saying
that candy should be sexy but the words
on the screen are saying candy is sexy
shoes is highly offensive like they
can't they they're all over the map with
what they do and that's why you know
it's all [ __ ] but listen to what he
says about about transitioning beer the
better that's the rule
the other big change is that the brown
eminem has quote transitioned from high
stilettos to lower block heels
tr quote transitioned
that's
and again it's this transphobia [ __ ]
where you go to a bar and you pick up on
a [ __ ] m m she's got a hot ass she's
got [ __ ] high heels on you get the m
m home you're gonna take her candy
coating off and do what you want to do
and then boom she's got tennis shoes and
she transitioned to an m m with tennis
shoes this is the [ __ ] garbage this
is the [ __ ] thought process and i
know i know i think we beat the
transphobic drum last week but it's only
because they keep beating this drum they
they want an enemy here and that's the
enemy because the eminem isn't it i mean
they know this [ __ ] this is really
[ __ ] dumb they're trying to turn any
issue they can cancel culture issue they
can into transphobia is what they're
trying to do because they want to cancel
trans people they want to make sure they
can't go in bathrooms they can't go to
schools they want to make sure that
they're [ __ ] in society they're
viewed as monsters which is [ __ ]
despicable and vile and and these girls
right yeah well these people's rights
need to be protected and they need to be
protected from fascists like like tucker
here so that's why tucker got
got the alpha cuck of the week alphacock
alpha maybe we should have a should we
have a sound alphacock
look at the alpha cuck mommy
[Laughter]
you know even a little kid would we
could point out an application yeah so
between our between our um
our great contestants here the winner of
the week was donald trump jr of course
of course it seems like a million years
ago that this happened but let's let's
let's give old donnie his due here
[Music]
[Music]
so there there is uh donald trump jr yay
he won coke spoke wins
[Laughter]
coke spoke i like that i always call him
booger sugar junior
that's that's the reason why he was on
the bonehead of the week yeah because of
his little his
whatever it is i don't know he
you know
don jr is uh obsessed with um
with hunter right he's always obsessed
with hunter biden and his laptop and all
this stuff but for someone who just
can't
it's just it's just like the way of the
way of a trump right like
of anyone in that family they are unable
to just step out of the limelight and
just kind of retire
and leave right oh no so sloppy i spilt
it everywhere oh stop my water
everywhere uh you're like don junior
over here yeah i know i know sorry guys
shopping yeah
yeah you know i i just i didn't
jump
but we're gonna watch the video here
it's it's funny because like
we played this earlier in the week where
uh laura ingraham like
parodied her that kate mckinnon's parody
of her which is really [ __ ] weird to
do yeah yeah like it's really weird to
do satire of the satire that's done of
you like that's real that's a real
weird dichotomy yeah but but it really
is like don jr is trying to to imitate
his dad saying joe biden yeah to impress
his dad which because he's good with
that
because he's completely obsessed he's
completely obsessed with not only hunter
biden and joe biden but his dad and i
believe it's because that he's jealous
that joe biden loves hunter right like
oh yeah like even though joe hunter
buying his complete [ __ ] up yeah and and
no one wants anything that's the
craziest part is like everyone in the
republican party is lining up to pay two
thousand dollars to take a picture with
this [ __ ] coke head that we're gonna
play
not no democrat in the world is lining
up to even get an autograph from hunter
yeah no one junior's like please love me
daddy please
please love me
uh so daddy
thank you may have some more yeah right
right oh my god so let's let's go to the
video uh mystery sullivan has it uh
posted here i this is the one and
so he's doing it in front of his empty
bookshelf you notice you notice
something in particular that's missing
on his bookshelf do you notice
like there's something
isn't it
is it a photo of
him and his dad no like like books like
just like books in general like oh yeah
does he even have his book up there well
i mean no i mean he's got this i don't
know what kind of alcohol this is i
don't know if it's like maker's mark or
whatever but he's getting he's got a
bottle alcohol up here it's probably
trump alcohol like some some brand he
started that never even made it outside
the door it might be i mean he's got
like a bunch of pictures and dollar
store frames and [ __ ] but no
no no books like no no no no you know he
used to he used to do this because when
i did my booger sugar junior video uh a
booger sugar and i i love that video and
i always post it when he's trending but
he used to do it in front of like his
his bat cave like he had this pegboard
full of pistols do you remember what he
used to do in front of that yeah yeah
like and then people started making fun
of him because these pistols behind him
you know were kind of made him look
inadequate like he was trying to muscle
up or something like he was trying to be
an alpha [ __ ] right right like he said
maybe maybe he should have been the
alpha but but he used to do it from that
so then he changed to the bookshelf that
has no books so i find that that funny
but also the [ __ ] the logo
the logo oh the goal can't even [ __ ]
do that junior logo yeah
yeah
it's it's it's on brand isn't it yeah
hey guys it's dan jr
just great you know crazy wants to be
like his dad you know uh well let's
let's let's play
and let's [ __ ] totally clown this
this clown yes you know you gotta put
joe bite in the same room with someone
you might uh let one rip
guys
joe biden
i mean it's it's it's you can't even
hardly
do it any better than what he does it
like right you know what i mean like
it's like you can't put anybody in the
room just jump at him
he'll let one rip
i i can't you can't even make fun of
this guy almost because it's almost like
he's doing a video that so
what i found funny was so i i looked at
i i got the original video that i posted
on facebook
uh
he posted so he did post his video in
november or end of november december
early time
um
and what i noticed if you go to his
facebook page he reposts the same video
every like almost every week wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait a second you're
talking about like so he made this video
has been reposted on his facebook page
like four times so wait wait a second
this isn't a new video no no no this
just came up because somebody came
across it okay so someone was brave
enough to go over and look at his
facebook pages like what the [ __ ] is
this and this video is like four or five
months old because we do that with our
videos right like we take a video yeah
and we'll repost it as it becomes
relevant right so he's like he's just
like recording these things and just
keep posting them so yeah not only did
he think this was good to post it once
he's reposting it like
four times
like you go through and you're like oh
that's the same one because it's like
biden can't read or like
something about the teleprompter like
biden can't read the teleprompter
whatever
and uh it was last week
and there was another one the previous
week
and then like the previous or two weeks
before that and then a week before that
and it's like so you think like his
benders are so [ __ ] heavy that he has
to record one when he's he's not such on
a heavy bender and then when he's on
heavy benders he has to yeah or he's
like you know what
this is
evergreen joe biden material and he puts
it up there and then he's like yes it's
great and then he posts another one like
there was the one where um tucker
carlson uh made the michael jackson joke
about nancy pelosi
and he did the videos like guys i just
got off the plane and i just before i
you know i just had to post this video
and do a reaction
and then
i was like wait this is weird this it
said it was like oh it was posted five
hours ago
i was like that's weird that
how many minutes ago i was like there's
something new happened and then i
watched i was like this is in fact the
same thing that he's referring to and
then i go back and i'm like oh he posted
it last week too and the week before
that
and the week like
he would think you would think that a
[ __ ] that claims to be this rich
and have you know be this smartness like
he would have social media managers that
would but he literally is doing all this
posting himself isn't he right
it's like you know if anyone doesn't
believe me feel free to go to donald
trump jr's facebook page and he will no
thank you
no
no thanks bro no i'm good i'm good yeah
let's let's watch the rest of this
[ __ ] train wreck
is what stands between us
yeah and the nuclear capable china
china joe biden
if
there's a serious crisis
with russia
who else would they call at three in the
morning he's the [ __ ] president if
there was a crisis who are they going to
call who else ghostbuster no and we
[ __ ] eight million people were like
yeah i want joe biden to take the
[ __ ] call
then you're dumb as dead
like you know what you know
that he's like you know
is the guy that is gonna get the call at
three in the morning and it's like what
else do you think would happen who do
you think would like to call because
last time i checked your dad was on the
[ __ ] at three in the morning sending
rage tweets
well he wouldn't have time to push the
[ __ ] button right oh my god it'd be
like uh mr trump president trump we need
to take this cause like hold on i'm i'm
getting a good one out here right now
so was there something else that he
trended for i want to believe that
there's something else oh there was i
mean there's several things that he's
trying to do
tara has this great picture that someone
posted uh captioned the picture did you
see this picture no
you didn't see this yet no oh my god
look at these dude chuckleheads he's
like dad please pay attention to me
and then he and then he's like joe biden
and then donald trump's like huh did you
wha
is he on twitter is joe biden's jeremiah
look at these clowns and she's like dad
please i i just need my allowance can i
have my alliance posted this and said
caption this picture i'll retweet it
here so you guys can go
have fun to caption this thing
but we'll go back to tara's caption
there's several there were several
really good captions so i'm sure if you
go to the quote tweets on this there's a
lot of good captions and i'm sure the
comments are um tara says i'm sorry
who are you again
for the hundredth time i told you i'm
your son
don jr who don jr never heard of him now
why won't my twitter account open
like literally look at this guy on the
phone
look at this oh my god and this is this
is the master races you know hero here
this is their golden calf look at this
guy they they called joe biden old and
feeble look at this guy he's not even
holding the phone right that ain't gonna
hold the phone and it looks like it
looks like don junior's not even looking
at him yeah i know he's looking past him
yeah you don't pay attention to me
dad please attention to me
and then they're not eating any food or
nothing you won't even feel there's also
someone else at the table here yeah and
like a pink shirt that might be here no
no no he's in a pink shirt someone else
is in the suit jacket
oh i see yeah yeah yeah now i see it's
kind of an optical illusion someone's
sitting in front of him this way it
could be it could be eric as well and
right he's not paying attention he's
like right
yeah right but but that you see that
they have no food or anything he can't
even feed his son right yeah well the
guy's broke so well you know
like if you want if you want your mickey
d's you're gonna have to get your mickey
mouse
if you want your food someone's gonna
pay for it and you gotta go in the
kitchen right right
maybe mexico will pay for his food okay
let's see what else is in this thread uh
you know we got this oh here we go he
came up last night
is this is this uh yeah
uh yeah i might be one of the clubs i'm
why do they have him on fox news what
the [ __ ] what he was on hannity that's
why because
yeah yeah well of course let's see
pastor in afghanistan i get to read
reports saying that intelligence i get
to read what is he read reports and what
is saying that russians may be launching
a cyber attack on america i don't think
so i imagine that's our people lying to
us to try to instigate us getting into
another war to distract from the
incompetence do you think our posture in
ukraine has anything like biden is doing
everything to keep us out of [ __ ] hot
war like everything
like the whole thing is to keep us out
of hot war not be in it what is he
talking about that this is this is more
of them trying to push the the putin
agenda and russia's agenda you know it
which is which is [ __ ] just
absolutely flabbergasting that that that
we have the the republican party is
pro-putin in this country pro-russia
well i mean they like authoritarians so
it's not surprising but i mean it's all
to own the libs you know like oh well we
want joe biden to go to war that way
that way we can use it against him in
the election like it's not like we don't
want him to go to work because the
american people don't want to they're
like cheering it on because they want
just like they didn't want to vote for
infrastructure right so that joe biden
didn't have a win
thing to do with his corrupt son raking
in millions over the years and this is
the way to cover it up that favors are
being called maybe one of these days
hunter biden's laptop will make it on
bonehead of the week ken here says only
fox news would be so callous and so
cynical how can they justify putting a
man who is so obviously under the
influence of drugs on camera i think
that's their brand though donald trump
jr should be i mean will i make a video
based on this did i watch this last
night and think to myself how can i do
this
possibly possibly will you see a video
with me in it as donald trump jr on fox
news
you're going to have permanent red eye
if you don't stop snorting coke just to
be i know i know i know the method
acting thing is the thing you like to do
but you know that's how we do in
hollywood
you got to lay off the coke you know lay
off the don junior video so you can lay
off the coke yeah and listen and the
stuff that i do
that he does it's shitty coke too let me
tell you it's so horrible yeah right
right it's it's [ __ ] cut up a lot
that's a lot all right well let's let's
give let's give the bonehead of the week
um his his one last dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us for bonehead of
the week and congratulations to booger
sugar junior don
donald j trump jr don't forget
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel check out uh the bonehead of the
week we will re-air this on sundays just
the bonehead at eight eastern so if you
want to watch just the bonehead part of
the show you can go watch it on the
youtube channel also subscribe to at
tony michael's pod the poll for bonehead
of the week is over there also follow me
and gabe as well
and until next week i guess you know
until next week we'll have another
bonehead of the week so go vote go vote
go vote
[Music]
[Applause]
all right well i think i think that was
a good bonehead of the week we we had uh
uh good good contestants this week we
had a fantastic winner what a great what
a great winner there for the boone of
the week what do you think
oh no yeah definitely i mean is that the
first time he's won or is he one before
did you because you had this picture oh
yeah i had the picture ready i don't
know if he won before yeah i can't
remember i'll blend these together yeah
well you know you know a lot of times
these are blowouts you know like it it
just starts and
they they win like within five minutes
right right exactly this one was pretty
close to the beginning but at the also
at the end like what i will say is
that uh
uh
every week there's always
so many contestants that come in later
on they're like late entries
and so we have to figure out like well
who do we get well we had one we're
choosing between like eight people right
to even do this poll like that day that
we did it we had like eight of them were
like well which ones and right we just
took the top three that we said because
we're like we'll just make the other
ones the alpha cuck and the [ __ ]
dishonorable mention like you could come
up with four more categories and still
have plenty of material to do with it
yeah but don't worry those people are
always waiting in the wings
ready to go whenever we say all right
you're up and like coach i'm ready to
play you know
that's what they're doing
they're just waiting for the attention
because that's what they want right
these people want more attention but in
this way we're just going to call them
[ __ ] boneheads right well you know
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them so so i do want to
make a few announcements here so monday
we're going to air the missy model
interview which is a fantastic interview
yep i had a lot of fun when we recorded
that interview with missy yeah she's
super smart um and the other thing too
is she's really funny and her parodies
her song parodies i didn't know she was
like she wrote music for disney and
netflix i had no idea about that
and it's no wonder it's no wonder that
her parodies are so good because
the experience that she has as a
songwriter and musician
but she she actually what i like about
the interview she like gave us this this
cue into how she like how she like comes
up with these parodies so you guys
should go follow her on tik tok and
instagram she's also on twitter we're
gonna try to drag her
drag her kicking and screaming over here
to twitter um to get her to post some of
her videos on twitter but she she does
have all that on her tic toc and
instagram and i believe it's at uh missy
model m-o-d-e-l-l
to follow her over here don't miss that
interview on monday that's gonna be a
fantastic interview we actually have one
we're recording this afternoon right are
we still we're okay that and we'll
announce that as soon as we get it
recorded in the can that's an exciting
interview i can't wait to ask uh him
questions that's going to be fantastic
yeah and not only that but he also had
his own his own issues with it yes yeah
that's right that's right
right so so i'm excited about that and
we gotta we got an interview next week
that we have scheduled with someone on
twitter so twitter's big in our
interviews in the next three or four
interviews so that's super exciting and
i also i haven't talked to gabe about
this but i've got a special interview
that i'm trying to work on that's going
to be really exciting really
stick around for that again every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central right
here on youtube twitter twitch don't
forget to follow at tony michael's pod
for the bonehead of the week poll and
you'll see all the the broadcasts there
on twitter you can go to twitch and go
to youtube follow us there subscribe to
all those channels like share you know
hit the bell notification again whatever
the hell we're supposed to say smash
that subscribe hit that like that's
right yeah whatever the hell it is there
you know point down go to the comments
leave comments i guess chris and he was
in our our local hate watcher uh was
late to the show today thanks for
joining us what a loser yeah what a
[ __ ] lead to the game yeah yeah man
you need to go donate since you were so
late chris yeah we appreciate we always
appreciate chris here with his comments
i mean
every single time he watches the whole
show i'm sure he'll go back and watch
the whole thing so yeah he's uh he's
he's definitely my uh my motivation you
know yeah yeah i like i like having hate
watching i i would i wish chris would
invite his alpha cuck friends i mean
yeah who knows yeah we'll have fun with
him the more the merrier and if anyone
wants to give us money along the way to
you know write us mention your name on
the air that's right that's right as
long as you're not being a racist piece
of [ __ ] bigot in the in the comments we
won't block you we will let you we'll
let you come in
yourself like you can do it yourself
absolutely we won't do anything all the
people in the chat love to talk to you
they love the chat with you yeah they
love the back and forth our fans you
know their motto there's a certain word
that we use here
before we go and i'm trying to think of
what it is um before we we'll see you on
monday but there's a word do you
remember what the word is gabe this
phrase
yeah it's uh [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born had asked me